we're going to turn now to the
disturbing new
disturbing new cova trend across the
country about a third of americans are
in high risk areas that's according to
the cdc the agency's director is
strongly recommending mask in public
indoor spaces we know how to do this
people this comes as daily coveted cases
are up about 26 percent from the
previous week and
hospitalizations are up 22 percent cbs
news medical contributor dr david agus
joins us now to help us make sense of
all of this i don't know if we can ever
make sense of it david but we're glad
you're here you know the numbers are
really very troubling so
how about what's causing it number one
and how bad do you think it's going to
get so the new omicron variants are
tremendously infectious which is why
it's just so easy to spread so the
numbers are going up
they're going to continue to go up over
the next several weeks we're seeing
people who are either not vaccinated or
vaccinated a long time ago get really
sick
and they're being hospitalized and
that's certainly a worrying trend that
being said we're going to live with it
we're not going to shut down we're not
going to have mass mandates but the
recommendation when you're in a crowded
place or you're close to someone wear a
mask please do that have consideration
for others it makes sense yeah it's
interesting now when you're on planes
they always they make an announcement
now as part of the warm-up to please
respect the decision of the person
sitting behind you whether beside you
whether you wear the mouse or not let's
all be respectful of the decisions
people make but we're also now starting
to hear stories of people getting covet
again you know there was a false belief
that if i got it once and i can't get it
good yeah i'm good but that's not
happening now no unfortunately not i
mean this virus is changing literally
dramatically and so when it does that
doesn't give you immunity to the prior
strain you had so we're seeing people
who had omicron december and january who
are getting omicron again
and so the virus is changing it's not
your immune system is bad or the
vaccines are bad per se it really is the
virus is changing so you're getting
different a different strainer different
part of homocrine yes so there's omicron
ba1 ba2 ba4
all of those are different ones and
they're radically different viruses
that's why we have to keep immunity at a
very high level with that booster and we
as a country are failing getting the
booster and i get the fatigue over it
yeah but please get that booster if
you're high risk especially let me
actually does the booster protect you
from getting cold because i had a
conversation with a family member and he
said i'm fully vaccinated i've seen
people that are boosted get coveted so
why do i need to get boosted if these
variants are coming and they're so
rapidly changing great question so
the vaccines prevent serious illness
they don't prevent upper respiratory
infection which is spreading the virus
gotcha so you can get mildly ill if you
have that booster but what we worry
about are the hospitalizations as
hospitals are filling up now as gail
said
we're not doing cancer surgeries and
heart surgeries and the entire country
suffers as the hospitals get full and we
can't have that so if you get that
booster you're going to have a mild cold
which is not bad you don't have that
booster you were vaccinated a year ago
it could be really worse so you could be
hospitalized we're hearing anecdotes
about people who take this five-day
course of pax levitt after they can
track covet and then they get a rebound
case uh they're only anecdotal but what
do you know about this it's real i mean
and so you know we all know people who
that's happened to i have dozens of
patients that's happened to pax of it is
a remarkable drug it blocks
hospitalization 95 plus percent but at
the same time it was very quickly
developed and probably the dose is
either too low or you need a longer
course because these people
get better they test negative and then
three four days later they start to test
positive again and that's why it's
frustrating david because you think i
got pax love it i'm good and now you're
telling that doesn't always work too
right but listen it works you didn't get
serious ill you weren't hospitalized but
you did test positive again
unfortunately and what we're probably
going to see is some newer data to make
it either a 10-day course or a slightly
higher dose in some people it's still
working but we're perfecting how it's
working and it's really important to
know that three to four days later you
test positive you are infectious so
watch out i'm sick of asking the
question but do you see light at the
tunnel when is it over i think we are
seeing light at the tunnel right we're
going back to a new normal here and the
new normal is you know we're going to
have these spikes up and down we're
going to put mass on take them off but
we're going to live with the virus we're
not hiding from it anymore and that's
going to continue to happen and we have
to stop the panic realize if we're
higher risk we need that booster maybe
we need to you know if we have any
symptoms take a test and then take the
drugs if we need to but at the same time
we're not going to panic we're not going
to shut down again we really have
learned and science is going to enable
us to go forward in a positive way but
it ain't over dr agus thank you so much
we appreciate you